i feel like the inevitable has to be
jay getting on a record with benny
that's inevitable that would be crazy
and that'd be crazy is is that something
that
i mean you don't ask for something like
that it's almost like the drake thing
like if he wants to do it he'll do it
type [ __ ] right
right right right right right right
right right right i ain't gonna lie i
asked though you did ask
yeah but that's nothing you could really
ask for you know what i'm saying i
should have worked that into the
management you know what
like look i'm a sign but i need i need
one i need one jay first
i need to i need a 16 of him talking
about selling cocaine right but i
understand and i'm saying of course i
want a whole verse but i'm not gonna lie
i understand that
his door is open to us right so i
understand that
it's some knowledge and certain [ __ ]
that i'm a
game that could be just as valuable you
know what i'm saying
like all of them to deal with the nfl
i knew that before it happened you know
i'm saying uh
uh what's your name i was in the rock
nation building somebody told me it's
like yeah watch what happened thursday
and then that square [ __ ] yeah you know
what i'm saying so yeah that [ __ ] was
crazy
i mean so like it's like he he
before he did the nfl deal that was the
day that i signed my contract
so he had to chop it up with us and then
we went to go do that so he was
explaining it to us so his door is open
you know what i'm saying so
it's a lot to be gained and i mean i'll
be one i don't be wanting
him to feel that that i just want and i
mean and i'm that type i just want the
song i want the song because
it ain't like that of course i would
take the [ __ ] so you you asked
for the song what what would they tell
you
nah i i examined so what did it what did
emery tell you
uh what did he say what did the whole
tell me
i think he was i think he was going out
of town i have one time i have flu out
here he had an idea
of a song that he wanted to do with me
and i flew out here to do the song with
him
you know what i'm saying but he was
moving around and doing [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying you know that's
that's the [ __ ] president time stamp
so what happened so he you flew out here
to do a song with him
he had the idea for so what was the idea
i i never got to
chop it up they was like yo hit me like
yo could you be out here you said he got
an idea i said yeah i come out there
that's like one of those things you
don't even think twice you're just like
i'm getting on the plane what happens
what i did i would have been driving a
car down the highway just all right guys
what happened in the sprinter
damn i mean but but but even for for him
to have an idea you know i mean if we
never do nothing
that's still crazy to me you know what
i'm saying that would be insane that
would be it would sound crazy i'm gonna
be honest
and if hove get on the song with me
hove gone he gonna give you that
aesthetic what the what what he feel
like
the people want to hear on some street
[ __ ] i believe because
i analyzed it because you know i i sat
down and thought about my jay-z feature
a few times okay look when he get on
them songs with
with jeezy the push of [ __ ] the drug
dealer's anonymous
he's going in he's going that's what i'm
trying to say so i feel like
you've been thought about this i've been
thought about that you know what i'm
saying i feel like he'd come on some
[ __ ] like that
and it'd be crazy